foreign
if you're looking for tips and tricks on
subscribing with Pub sub stay tuned hi
I'm Chloe and in this video I'll be
sharing six best practices when
subscribing with Pub sub let's Dive In
number one attach your subscription
before we talk about subscribing to Pub
sub it's important to remember you'll
need to have a subscription first a
subscription is attached to a topic and
you can attach one or many subscriptions
to an individual topic make sure you
have a subscription attached or have
topic retention enabled before you start
publishing messages to ensure no
messages are lost
number two
choose the right subscription
when you create a subscription
specifying the type of message delivery
is key Pub sub currently offers three
types of message delivery that
correspond to the following three types
of subscriptions
pull subscriptions push subscriptions
and bigquery subscriptions
make sure that you take time to choose
the right type of message delivery for
your subscription want more details on
what type of message delivery is right
for you learn more about each type in
our documentation linked below
number three process before
acknowledgment
messages should be processed before they
are acknowledged Cloud Pub sub will not
redeliver a message if it's been
acknowledged make sure you process your
message first before acknowledging it
number four acknowledge messages
be sure to acknowledge messages
if a message is redelivered then all the
message received after that message for
the same ordering key will also be
redelivered whether or not they were
already acknowledged for example if a
subscriber receives messages 1 2 and 3
of the same ordering key and message 2
is redelivered then message 3 is
guaranteed to be redelivered as well
number five use streaming poll
for maximum throughput and lowest
latency you may want to consider the
streaming pull model over the push model
or the unary pull model
the streaming pulse service API relies
on a persistent bi-directional
connection to receive multiple messages
as they become available
unlike the unary pull method this
maintains a constant connection to the
server and receives messages
continuously
streaming poll is fully supported by Pub
sub client libraries for ease of use
you can learn more about streaming poll
and flow control in our documentation
linked below and number six use flow
control
when using streaming poll via our
official client libraries we recommend
enabling flow control settings by
configuring a Max for outstanding
messages on a subscriber client to avoid
overwhelming any underprovisioned
subscriber with too many messages to
process
this also prevents you from starving
subscribers which have the capacity to
process messages
there you have it six best practices for
subscribing with Pub sub thanks for
joining and keep an eye out for more
best practice videos and take a look at
our Pub sub documentation for even more
tips and tricks on subscribing with Pub
sub
[Music]